SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY:This is primarily a
question and answer show, so
if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
MANO MARKS: Hi, welcome
to our latest Maps
Developer live event.
This week we are talking with
Raleigh Seamster from the
Google Earth Outreach team.
I'm Mano Marks, sorry.
This is Raleigh right here.
And we apologize for getting a
little bit of a late start.
Raleigh is from, as I mentioned,
the Google Earth
Outreach team.
And she just organized a really
amazing event last week
called Geo for Good.
So we asked her to come in this
week to talk to us about
what happened.
So Raleigh, can you talk a
little bit about what Google
Earth Outreach is, and what the
Geo for Good event was?
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: Sure, so
Google Earth Outreach is a
program which helps nonprofits
and public benefit
organizations use Google Maps
in order to visualize their
cause and message
to the world.
And as part of the program
we offer a lot
of different things.
We offer software grants
to nonprofits.
We offer trainings, both online
and in person, as well
as many other resources
on our website.
And so what we were doing last
week was holding a three-day
workshop that we called the
Geo for Good user summit.
Now since we launched in 2006,
we've held many, many
different trainings all over the
world of different types.
This summit was the
first of its kind.
It was a special event.
And the purpose of
this summit--
usually we're working with
groups that may not be as
familiar with Google's
mapping tools.
But this time around we were
bringing our non-profits we
know, different hall of famer
non-profits that have already
produced amazing work in Google
Earth and Maps, as well
as some new ones.
And we're bringing them here
to Google headquarters in
Mountain View to refresh
them in all the amazing
developments in these products
that have happened over the
last couple of years, as well
as some completely new tools
like Google Maps Engine and
Google Earth Engine.
So the basic structure of the
summit was to have hands-on
sessions in all of these
different tools, as well as
break out sessions, giving
participants the opportunity
to explore and do deeper dives
on topics like KML
coding and Maps API.
MANO MARKS: Cool.
So we have actually here a few
demos that Raleigh has
identified from participants
in the summit.
So we just want to go through
a few of these.
This first one here-- if
we can put that up--
is from Living Oceans.
And why don't you tell us a
little bit about what the
purpose of the site is.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: Yeah, sure, so
Living Oceans Society their
mission is to protect British
Columbia specific coastline.
And so they work a lot on topics
of marine planning and
conservation.
And they had all of these
amazing maps on paper.
And so they've been doing a lot
with Google tools in order
to put these maps online so
both stakeholders and the
public can explore.
And this map in particular is an
example of how they've used
Google Maps Engine in order to
bring in different map layers
onto the same map.
It has this nice widget that
lets you turn layers off and
on and understand
what they mean.
And then you can click on the
individual points to explore
more information.
It's very interactive.
And they have this embedded
right on their website.
MANO MARKS: So here
you can see it's
got interesting layers.
Kayak routes, ferry routes,
incidents where there were
vessels, protected areas, and
you can turn those on and off.
And you see they display here.
So this is using the Maps API,
and it's using Fusion Table
Layers to render a number of
these different data layers.
And you can see how you can just
turn those on and off.
Let's take a look at
I Love Mountains.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: So this is
another example of a great
organization we've been
working with since the
beginning of our program.
Appalachian Voices is a
nonprofit based in Appalachia
that works to raise public
awareness about coal mining's
impact on the region.
They've done a number of
different projects over the
years and this one in particular
is using Maps API
to display data layers.
So they're pulling in from
various national data sets
about the impacts of
coal mining on
health in the region.
So what you see right now, for
example, is data on life
expectancy changed by county
in Appalachia.
And if you can see it, there's
green markings where coal
mining is happening.
And then the red indicates the
areas in which the life
expectancy has lowered by
a great percentage.
And so you can really overlay
these two data sets using Maps
API and see how the
data correlates.
MANO MARKS: Right, so they're
using I believe KML layers to
render the different regions
where the [INAUDIBLE]
maps basically.
The individual areas where you
see differences in life
expectancy.
You see where red is-- you
actually see this decrease a
half a year to a year.
And dark red, such as in this
region, of more than a year in
the last decade.
So in the last decade, people
living in these areas have
lost basically a year of
expectancy from their life.
And they've got other
data ranges here.
So you've got overall well
being, birth defect indexes,
and a whole bunch
of other stuff.
And you can see overall well
being for a pretty big swath
of this area has just
dramatically dropped.
And I just really like this as
a nice, very clean, easy to
use and understand way to tell
the story about mountain
[INAUDIBLE].
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: If
you see above,
there's a get embed code.
And they do a great job of
making their maps shareable
across the web.
MANO MARKS: Right, so you can
have a share embed code here
and it's just an iframe.
It's like putting a video in
your blog or putting a map
right in your blog.
Yeah, a really nice way to
pull that all together.
Let's take a look at Eyes
On The Forest here.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: Sure,
this is a project
from the last year.
And what's interesting about
this is the WWF and an
Indonesian nonprofit called
Eyes On The Forest--
MANO MARKS: WWF is--
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: World
Wildlife Fund.
Thank you.
And basically what they're doing
is they're working to
protect wildlife in Sumatra.
There's a lot of really unique
animal species there such as
the Sumatran tiger, rhinos,
and elephants.
And the palm oil production and
pulp paper industry on the
island are very quickly
deforesting and degrading the
natural habitats that these
animals live in.
And they were looking for a way
to really communicate this
message to CEOs of companies
that buy the paper and
buy the palm oil.
And show the impact that this
is having on the island.
So what they did is they brought
all of their data sets
about wildlife habitat ranges,
carbon stocks, forest ranges,
protected areas, and stored
it in Google Maps Engine.
And then they're using Google
Maps API as the front end, the
interface, through which
the public can
explore these data layers.
And it's quite--
Mano's going to show you in
a minute-- but it's quite
interesting, because there's a
pull-out menu that when you
hover over a certain data
set it tells you more
about that data set.
So it's really geared towards
explaining to the public these
complicated data sets.
MANO MARKS: Right, so as you can
see here from the map if I
hover over, say the Sumatran
rhinoceros, it tells me a lot
about what's going on there.
And a lot about the rhinos and
how they are critically
endangered.
And you can also select the
different wildlife ranges.
You can see in 2007 and
then the 1980s.
And this follows a fairly
similar pattern we saw on a
number of these different sites,
where you have this
left nav where you pull up
individual data layers.
Because there's so much data
you want to be able to give
the user and interactivity that
allows them to select
what they're viewing and
what they're not.
And I particularly like that
they're using Maps Engine with
the Google Maps API, because
that allows them to display
just really large, large
amounts of data.
Now Google Maps Engine is--
for those of you who
don't know--
it's a new serving technology
from Google.
We released it last year.
And it's basically storing all
your GIS data and then serving
it out over Google's
infrastructure.
And it allows people to use both
the Maps API but also to
use their native data format.
So you can upload shape files
or KML files or whatever GIS
data formats that you have--
those vector and raster data--
upload them to Maps Engine and
then we handle all the serving
out of that data.
And you can obviously combine
it with our data as well.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: And the cool
thing to note about Google
Maps Engine is that eligible
non-profits can apply for a
grant of Google Maps Engine
through the Google Earth
Outreach program.
We'll share with you some links
as to how you find out
more information about that.
MANO MARKS: We'll put links in
the description of the video
once it's posted.
Let's take a look at this
Living Oceans site here.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: So again,
Living Ocean Society they're
working to communicate different
marine planning
issues to the public.
And this site is an example of
using the Google Earth plug-in
API in order to share
different data
layers on the map.
So they have that left hand nav
that you can turn on and
off layers.
But the cool thing is that since
they're using the Earth
API, you can tilt and rotate
and explore in the 3D view.
MANO MARKS: Right, and so you
can see here turning on and
off layers within
the Earth API.
And you just get this real
nice sense of the ocean.
I'd like to see them put
something under the ocean,
because you can actually go
under the ocean with the Earth
API and see things on
the ocean floor.
I don't think we have a lot of
good terrain data down there
in this particular region.
Yeah, makes for a very nice
smooth experience and allows
you to display a lot of data
directly in the browser.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: We find that
using Google Earth resonates
especially with environmental
organizations that are working
with issues dealing with the
land and the landscape.
And they love being able to
use Google Earth's rich
terrain and 3D imagery in order
to communicate those
issues to the public.
MANO MARKS: Right, and then have
that on the plug in right
on their website allows them
to have a nice smooth 3D
experience.
And I wanted to show one
map that I show.
This is actually just a sample
that I developed.
There is an organization called
Save the Elephants, and
they produce a GP extract of one
particular elephant over a
year period in this
park within Kenya.
And you can see on here that all
I did was I took the GPX
track and loaded it
into the browser.
And then just parsed
it as XML.
And using our new heat map and
symbols capabilities that we
put into the Google Maps
API this summer.
So the heat map is a layer and
the symbols are symbols on
pulley lines in this case
but also on markers.
I'm going to zoom in
a little bit here.
You can see I actually put a
little symbol of an elephant
on the line, and I'm animating
it as it's
moving around the line.
So you can see the little
elephant moving there.
And basically what we do is we
allow you to do custom symbols
on maps using SVG paths.
So we then parse those SVG
paths, render them into
canvas, and overlay them
on top of the map.
And here I'm just changing the
position every few seconds.
I'm changing the position of
the symbol along the line.
Just a very small incremental
percentage.
But I can turn that
on and off.
I can interact basically
with this dynamically.
I can change the color, because
this is all happening
in the browser.
It happens very quickly.
It's all rendered
in the browser.
I can turn on and off the
heat map as well.
And in this case, you can see
I also used arrows on the
lines between the waypoints.
So I just added a symbol,
a repeating symbol,
that repeats every--
I think it was 100 pixels
on the line.
You can see an arrow that
basically tells you the
direction that that elephant was
going at that particular
time between different
waypoints.
That then turned into a breakout
session where that
was mostly what I talked about
during that session.
Any last minute thoughts
Raleigh?
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: I guess just
if you're interested to know
more about what non-profits are
doing with Google Maps,
Google Maps API, Google Earth,
head to our website
earth.google.com/outreach.
We have tons of case studies
and examples there.
We have a section where
you can read about
our software grants.
So if you are at a nonprofit,
or are working with a
nonprofit, you can encourage
them to apply
for a grant if needed.
We also have a developer
marketplace, where developers
that like working with
nonprofits and are looking for
work with nonprofits can list
themselves in a marketplace.
And we also have a page
of training resources.
So if you're a developer working
with nonprofits, and
you want to give them some basic
training on how to use
these tools, we have materials
that can help you do that.
MANO MARKS: Great, well thanks
for coming in and talking to
us today Raleigh.
And we'll post links to a lot
of these samples and to the
Earth Outreach resources
in the video and
on our Google+ page.
Thanks everybody for watching.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: Thank you.